in novoazovsk residents watched as
shells rain down on their town clashes
between pro-russia separatists and
ukrainian soldiers showed no sign of
stopping novoazovsk lies in a
strategically important location on the
road that links Russia to Crimea 300
kilometers away it's also on the as of C
which has large oil and gas reserves
some residents like tatianna halle-loo
buff and her son Anatoly hope it will be
safer on the other side of the border in
Russia for the morning I had to come
back through the battle zone to get my
mother yes but I was dodging the bullets
God have mercy on me I got through I'm
leadership the other show this in Kiev
ukrainian President Petro poroshenko
told supporters that his meeting Tuesday
with Vladimir Putin in Minsk had been
quote very effective you make it cheap
gonna velocity at the talks I clearly
stressed that there will be no
bargaining over sovereignty territorial
integrity the independence of our
country or the sovereign choice of the
Ukrainian people which is to side with
Europe boonton emotion back in eastern
Ukraine the fighting continues taking a
further toll on civilians